gun bash my name for you
welcome back to afraid of monsters
finally fire finalmente as the fine okay
whatever this is the final episode of
afraid of monsters I'm sorry it was
delayed I lost the save file and oh my
god do we have to is this what I yes I
have to walk this corridor again I hate
I like creepy faces come on bro I'm not
scared you think I'm scared of you
creepy faces
you guys okay let's just it hate it go
like this
alright okay lovely lovely alright we're
out of the period wall and there's a pen
there they are watch again oh oh no
you're not supposed to be in here we
have to teach them a lesson
apparently now I learned that if you
right-click with the gun you can put
what the hell what are you made of let
me shut their strong those like all my
ammo sorry fine girl I'm sorry you have
to live YouTube you're lucky I'm a cat
named Annie sonic I wasted enough time
on you good out of it
no one likes definitely no one likes it
animate all right oh no it's a sperm
shooter oh he's a feisty one
oh right in the face I'll tell you doing
he shut me right in the face
what should I do you think you're tough
huh
you think you're talking with their
sperm shooting ability oh ow Holly
sentence keeps okay whoa stop shooting
this version he was a feisty one
alright now we must jump over here
gotta charge it charge it come on come
on come on oh no no no all right no no
okay I'm skinny go all right shall let's
go over here
whoa whoa whoa can I jump oh there's a
ladder you lovely fantastic let's go
down here
Oh charlie you scared me Charlie what
are you doing here Charlie Charlie I
know you're upset but we can't be
friends I'm sorry it's not my decision I
don't hang out with people in
wheelchairs in this game oh it's not
about your disability charlie I promise
it's about your attitude all right
you're always so frustrated there you go
Charlie Charlie back off
I'm so sorry Charlie I we could have
been brothers but no all right Oh Oh
what the hell girl
what back up whatever you miserable I
see your [ __ ] what are you what I saw
your face take the top ah
back off all of you
I've got to speak okay I'm gonna fetch
in front of night I had something up
here let's go there where's Charlie
Charlie why did he go I thought it was
just taking a nap
Charlie Charlie silly she'll Sally Rock
Ruben I'm so sick of your [ __ ] Ruben so
full of [ __ ] are you huh speak I will
teach you once and for all there you go
there you go oh no your brother Rubens
brother look at me when I kill you
look at me hate it hate all of it
alright here we go here lovely oh no
nipple guys all of them are [ __ ]
coming off
[ __ ] nipple gallery flirts ellen
degeneres she would be so pissed off
when she sees you being all naked and
stuff
stupid nip okay when will they learn
never learn and never learn do we have
here
ah professor I can finally take Pete
what the hell did I do oh no God what
are you doing do I calm down door I will
just and take think it huh
door obviously don't want me in here do
you you're walking against me to door
all right you got plenty of to full
health I expect something bad happening
soon if they give you they give you full
health all right
we open the last gate of doom the gate
of damage all right I always wanted to
use this in my batch can I do it can I
no all right let's go in here things is
right it's here that case be gentle with
me the ijen oh no oh all right this is
where we came so now we go in here no I
meant in here of course it's obvious I
like this careful cuz there are monsters
oh no back up I have an axe I don't want
to kill you I like your face but okay
there you go your dad hey Donna how did
you feel you don't feel anything just
your dad turn to one out oh that one
holy [ __ ] don't scare me like that send
what else but teach my last sense likes
free lessons
Oh axe knees right here baby alright
there we go
lovely lovely nothing up oh no dragons
shut up dragon someone likes you [ __ ]
I got your [ __ ] dragons all day all
night long day or two left
Oh
Oh No such an idiot what the hell did I
do that for
Oh it saves here awesome ha that's gonna
get dragons oh no all right no [ __ ]
hard can be all right there we go
dragons see you on the other time oh no
stop shipping oh no this is not get die
got enough for this no sir
oh no oh no this is creepy oh stop it
seriously Hanoi the didgeridoo guy
started playing again what what can you
do what do we have here holy [ __ ] that's
a lot of ammo I expect something bad
soon lovely table now from probably from
like ah this Celtic oh I come as can't
take forever
I'm so tired okay not really nervous I
sank that's gonna stop me from my glory
hey poke ball hi another poke bar and I
don't just keep following the poke ball
Ashutosh which one first googly duel it
off king kelana cough cough rolana Bing
Cabana Oh Lu Doo Lu I whatever they do
it right oh I think I did all right
climb that [ __ ] or hump it or hug it
there we go
that wasn't so bad was it sorry my egg
he was licking really leg was itching
I'm sorry I poke ball show me the way
poke ball poke ball bah bah
why don't I never communicate this is
how the game started by the way so
oh look at this look at the
oh no football how Paul do you want me
to press that I don't know what I feel
about that football I don't know what I
like it oh no what did I do
oh that's ha ha ha no I just takes you
accident [ __ ] stay down Ruben's
wrong brother are you Ruben father
perhaps no you're not you which adopted
like I don't know
back up oh stop got that come on captain
now
I don't know back off all of you I will
teach you smash me I don't even know
what it's called anybody it it's all of
it it tastes my language who's shooting
oh no he's rubbing arms army get them
all of them die Robert Rob's army oh
that's what you get are you angry
yeah the people didn't let Gilman play
didn't let you play
I'm sorry sir sorry hey there's a poke
ball back you know how I go here all
right like a PA for you wish
bow-bow bow-bow my poke ball my papa
Oh more Papa it's the white no way I
don't like this I don't know hug bond of
lightness wait a second can I shoot you
oh no what is going on here what it's
dark
what the hell what what should I get
what what hey you I just got off such an
idiot
all right let's get goddamn it oh I did
it
Oh what's going on here oh it's your
mama in the background on the painting I
just said nice huh what I guess is the
ending
oh no snappy snooze the cops are after
me oh no what did I do
maybe it was like he was on drugs and
stuff and then he shot oh yes this is
what I thought we killed all the people
that we thought were zombies
I guess police bill ha ha police vid
what are you doing Emily's been well
it's been pirate I never talk to me I
don't get a politican ha all right so I
guess I was the ending I'm not sure if I
will play the other maybe
[Music]
that's place I was expecting stop
traffic